wolverine is going to be the first
mutant introduced
maybe just hinted but will be introduced
in falcon with the soldier
she'll blink mutants into the
and we'll mcu right after this
hey
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars uh oh i'm
in the driver's seat again juan division
and the falcon and the winter soldier
are both gunning to launch marvel's
phase four with reports that one
division can actually drop as early as
october
of this year there's evidence that both
shows could introduce
mutants to the mcu mutants baby
what we want to know is who's gonna do
it first and how
this is rogue theory the podcast which
brings you the wildest
nerdy hot takes done by hot boys in high
stakes rumbles
i am the honorable judge thomas michael
beck told and with me today to go head
to head to pitch
their best theories our new rockstars
resident nerd genius
eric voss hello thank you for having me
back i'm ready to go
rogue yes eric yes and our returning
guests the very
talented very funny eric awusu hey thank
you guys for having me i'm ready to come
at voss's jugular
let's go we only have two panelists
today like i said because we're doing a
cage match style this is gonna be a
brawl a battle royale
two men enter two men will also leave
because it's not that kind of show
they will shake hands at the end uh
digitally today without further ado we
have
the eric bowl eric bowl eric
spoiler alert and eric is gonna win
today all right
one division and the falcon and the
winter soldier are coming and they're
coming hard
and in one of these shows we're likely
to get the mcu's first
official hint of mutants in this
universe
erica wusu you'll be arguing for one
division okay
eric voss you'll be arguing for falcon
and the winter soldier
will cut these promos into three rounds
for round one you're gonna have three
minutes like i said to make your general
case
for your mcu mutants okay go wrong my
sons
your three minutes begin now this is how
one division is going to introduce
mutants into the mcu
okay so according to the powers that be
one division is the first thing that
we're gonna see in this new
phase four version of the mcu the last
thing we saw was uh
spiderman far from home right okay so
one division uh is going to adapt the
events
from the house of m comic books kinda
sorta so in the trailers we see that you
know
wanda scarlet witch is kind of a
homemaker she's a different kind of
sitcom sets
blinking in between different realities
like uh
not i dream of genie yeah yeah you slash
bewitched
like a little twinkle of the nose and a
little winky wink magic happens
her vision or a couple we see two
cradles
uh they have babies they're twins and
what i think
is that those twins are billy and tommy
shout out to you
yes um who are their twins or their twin
sons yeah
already women who are their twin sons
from the comic books so now in the house
of m
a lot of wild stuff happens but mainly
the thing is
wanda taps into this thing called chaos
magic which allows her
almost infinite power she changes
reality she's not happy with the way
things are and at one point she says no
more mutants
and then just things go haywire so i
think
kind of a reverse will happen in uh one
division the tv show on disney plus
give me a check disney i just plugged
y'all yes uh
where she'll blink mutants into
the mcu mutants haven't been identified
in
the mcu as of yet they've been enhanced
individuals
uh stuff like that super serum soldiers
but wanda will blink
and wish and just kind of make mutants
happen in this mcu
she's gonna do it in her tv show it's
gonna be awesome it's gonna be fantastic
boom drop the mic until next round wow
chills you know what that
that was such a compelling compelling
first round that i didn't even time you
so was that three minutes
you know what it felt like three minutes
in my world my dimension the tommy world
where everything is very hairy all right
eric uh
eric foss you're up next give me what
you got sending the timer in a strict
three minutes here
[Laughter]
all right you gotta be out of your
goddamn line my friend
because here's where you're wrong while
definitely one division seems to be
setting up
uh tommy and billy and those cradles i
don't think
the word mutant will be uttered in one
division and yes there are some reports
saying it's going to be moved up
to october but we don't really know some
other reports are saying it's going to
be like spring 2028
it's all over the map it's rumors my
friend just rumors
and here's what we do know about vodka
winter soldier that show
is gonna explore the relationship
between superheroes and the government
that show is gonna go into the history
of captain america a history that in the
comics
inspired the history of weapon x and as
i have theorized and as
fortnite has confirmed the new shield
that sam wilson
bears is not made of vibranium but
proto-adamantium and you can't have
adamantium without wolverine in this
world we're going to explore the history
of that shield
the history of adamantium and we're
going to see what the next now mutants
already exist in this
world and we're going to see how
wolverine not the maximoff clan
and and magneto and all this wolverine
is going to be the first mutant
introduced
maybe just hinted but will be introduced
in falcon winter soldier
mark my words oh my god
that was that was brisk
that was that was intense that was angry
that was a little bit erotic i
i gotta say guys both of those takes
were incredible
but i am a tough judge okay uh my record
on the bench has been
uh pretty disgraceful uh a lot of
complaints a lot of ethics violations
but
one thing i'm known for is allowing
people to
uh continue to plead their case i'm i'm
still not convinced here but for round
two
i'm gonna give you each uh two
additional minutes here to go even roger
with these theories okay
so any inside scoops you might have from
your sources i want to point out
someone doubted my source the other week
about uh mcu contracts that i know from
a person who literally signed
that contract if you got inside sources
uh
you could we i will verify them for you
okay so if you have a chance that you
get an inside scoop now it's time to
drop on us
boss we're gonna have you go first this
round give us what you got two minutes
okay i got i got two more minutes of
heat coming your way
uh guys so some some
interesting news just came out about
falcon winter soldiers some casting
reports
they are casting a yakuza biker and like
another yakuza gang member on that show
so why is that important well an end
game we saw hawkeye
taking down some yakuza people this is
this is important to the world of the
mcu
and on a leaked set photo that came out
someone saw a biker gang jacket with a
red demon face on the back that many
believe
to be ogun the uh the
mcu villain that is tied to wolverine's
origin
so why introduce a yakuza person with
this specific logo on the back if you're
not going to be digging into the history
of wolverine
this is a ripe opportunity to deal with
the whole conflict
between the government and the way they
have tried to control superheroes
that is definitely the conflicts uh sam
wilson has been
setting up for his entire mcu existence
is
is he a government super soldier like
happis or is he his own hero that is the
story
of the x-men and the different
legislation that's been passed on the
x-men and the attempts by
senator kelly and other types to try to
control them and that is the story we're
going to explore
through wolverine's nick oh wow
oh my god another sharp efficient
pleating of your case
eric very nice there very uh some
tantalizing details
wussu i i i gotta say i i i'm looking
forward to hearing
your rebuttal to this i'll have you go
now two minutes well
it's a bad thing for voss that i have a
sweet tooth because i'm about to take a
bite
out of his candy
with that awful tank
now x-men actor who played quicksilver
uh his name is evan peters
he was cast in a mystery role in one
division
so my theory is that he's gonna flash
his way in
that's that's the that's the dc flat
fast guy he's gonna
silver his way in cross the streams here
he never crossed streams he's going to
quicksilver his way in
for one of the blinks uh and in the
comic uh house of them
at one point uh scarlet witch
brings quicksilver piedro back to life
with some of her
crazy chaos magic so anything's possible
anything's up for grabs evan peters has
been cast in this thing
he's probably gonna come back as
quicksilver and that
is evidence right there that mutants
will infiltrate
the mcu via what falcon and captain
america
no now now they're gonna come in
via one division with her blinky and her
twitchy and her magic fingers
bing bang boom bao take that and that's
what erika wusu was cooking
wow wow wow that is
uh i'll be honest uh eric eric wusu
started off much more polite than eric
boss in this fight but in the end
he did drop he didn't have to take a
bite out
trying to take a bite out of your sweet
sweet candy ass and for that
we know that it has gotten real we have
one more final round of arguments so
each side is going to present it and
then i'll give my final ruling
and my ruling will be final it will be
notarized it'll be sent
to the uh the smithsonian where it will
stay in a vault for 500 years
before it is released to the public each
of you will get 60 seconds that's one
american minute also one canadian minute
really a minute anywhere in the world to
hit your bottom line
here's my question why do mutants have
to be introduced the way you pitch them
compel me here how will your vision set
up the mcu in a crazy way
bring us home boys erica wusu you're
going first your 60 seconds begin
meow i'm gonna use those 60 seconds
those 60 american seconds
very officially yes but to start i'm
going to say that
eric boss is a candy ass just because
i'll come back now anyway
my remaining with my remaining 45
seconds
my theory is the correct theory because
one division is the first phase four mcu
show that's gonna premiere
sorry my knee was in the shot it's gonna
premiere
and it's gonna introduce mutants why
because evan peters is coming in is
quicksilver
he's gonna rapid fire his way into it
and it's gonna be largely based on the
house of m
storyline from the comic books which
sees wanda
messing with the reality of time and
space
and also her powers are very similar
looking to the effects of the reality
stone her
red mystic magic powers reality stones
red mystic goo
so she's gonna mess with reality she's
gonna introduce mutants that way and i
think that she's not only gonna
introduce mutants
she's also gonna introduce other marvel
property creature type thing she's going
to introduce celestials she's going to
introduce
zombies she's going to introduce
vampires
michael morbius is getting his own movie
eventually
we saw him interact with the vulture
played by michael keaton who was in
spider-man uh homecoming and spider-man
was in the mcu's civil war and other
movies
so michael morbis is a mutated vampire
we are well over a minute sir
is anything's possible divisions how
we're doing it
wow i like it you know what once you
started to attach the strings like a
conspiracy theory of like
michael morbius was in the same room as
michael keaton who played adrian tombs
the vulture who we know is this
i really started to connect with that
because god knows yes
you're right all masterminded 9 11.
uh great okay eric voss your final
rebuttal
all right i'm going to quote our future
president or paraphrase and say
i'm gonna let you finish i did let you
finish but my theory is the best of all
time
full time and here is why as much as i
want to see one division open up the
multiverse
uh theoretically blip anything in our
reality just through a matter of a
witch's blink
i think it is simpler than this i think
the mutants already exist in our
universe don't we want
to not change your story too much just
imply their histories are the same
they were just in the background why
can't we say that westchester county
during the battle of new york was
fighting off their own chitauris
and we get to revisit each of the uh
past
mcu battles just through the eyes or eye
of scott summers
or uh through the vantage point of
aurora monroe as she's floating over
channeling thor's lightning from the
battle of new york to blow up another
leviathan
we can revisit everything in the mcu
just through the lens of the fantastic
four
of the x-men by just hinting that
adamantium already exists in this
universe
in the form of this new shield weapon x
already exists through uh project exodus
and your knee came in the shot i'm
giving you two knees my friend
could pop a squat a papa boss as i tell
you the story
winner soldier neither one of you even
coming close to obeying the one minute
limit but both of you
coming close to making my heart explode
from action
wow but this is gonna be really tough
for me here's how i kind of score this
and again my decisions are final and you
will have to live with the shame uh
of of losing if i do decide that is the
case first round
boss you had me at wolvery okay you
brought up wolverine
you said the magic words that every man
with the
heart of a of a of a young boy in his
heart i'm gonna say that in a way that
doesn't seem so creepy
every man revisiting his childhood wants
wolverine to come back into his life
you had me at round one eric awusu you
had me in round two with just straight
up logic
evan peters is cast in the show why are
they casting him in the show
if he's gonna play a completely
different character he's gonna have to
be
cgi or wearing prosthetics or something
like that because you cannot have this
person
playing a different character in the mcu
that would be like johnny storm being
captain america
that would be insane they would never
right they would never do that okay
however in round three it was very tough
the the moments were compelling the
arguments were compelling but i do have
to agree with vos
that it is more marvel style it is more
marvel style
they'd love to show flashbacks from old
movies
where they could justify that this thing
has been
you should have known this all along
there's a very sort of like
person who's read one more book than you
in a series
smugness to marvel movies where they're
like you know in spider-man
uh far from home they were like yeah if
you were paying attention in the first
iron man you wouldn't see this guy like
this was a this was a
an employee of obadiah stain or you know
when they love to go back
and show like moments whether they're
even real or they're just reshoots or
something from a different angle or
made up in a on a computer it just seems
more marvel style to me to introduce
this as
we've been insinuating this for a long
time so my verdict
is round one goes to eric voss good job
gentlemen both of
hey and you know ultimately at the end
of the day this may just be decided on
release day and how fast they can finish
reshoots on [ __ ] winter soldier
you know if one just drops before the
other that if they both mention mutants
it might just be a matter of releases i
would say it would stand to reason that
both are probably
have a decent chance of introducing
mutants it probably will come down to
who
enjoys it first because they're going to
work
together like the shows are going to
probably push towards you know
what is it we're in phase four now it
would stand to read or
are are all of our dreams could be
dashed and uh mutant isn't mentioned
at all in the mcu until like 2025.
totally popular that is absolutely
possible well i mean let's be honest
these movies might not be coming out
until 2025.
if we all just don't wear our stupid
masks be a superhero
and put your mask on how hard is it how
stubborn are you
what's the matter with you don't tread
on me don't tread on yourself but
i have a medical a made-up medical
condition uh
because i've never read the ada but now
it um it conveniently fits my political
views
yeah breathing breathing is hard for me
too i have a medical condition called i
ate fast food five days a week for ten
years okay
that doesn't mean i shouldn't wear a
mask i'm still at risk
to to infect other people put a mask on
but right now
we need to cool off and we need to
retreat to our corners because the eric
bowl
is a little too hot to slurp okay we
gotta let it rest we gotta let it settle
you know let all the flavors marinate
and let's hear a few words from our fine
sponsors who help us bring rogue theory
to you
every week if you're an e-commerce
seller right now is a wild time and ship
station is here to help when we've tried
to ship things in the past like new
rockstar's merch it was confusing to
figure out what is shipped
and what hasn't and how much it all cost
shipstation helps online sellers of any
size get orders out quickly
save money on shipping costs and keep
customers happy
to my knowledge that is the most
important thing a happy customer is a
returning customer
they'll get you the shipping rates
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies we're talking the big boys
we're talking plato
we're talking lego okay all the bigwigs
okay
it's the fastest easiest and most
efficient way
to manage and ship your orders just a
few clicks and you'll be managing your
orders
and getting your product to happy
customers ship station they make it easy
and that's good for a person like me
with limited intellect they work with
all the major carriers and their
interface brings your products together
whether you're selling them on etsy
amazon or your own website
tommy t's for instance is my website it
sells graphic keys that are misspelled
uh it's great
ship station is the number one choice of
online sellers you'll ship
more and less time with the best rates
available right now you can try
shipstation
for re for 60 days when you use the code
rogue
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of delivery culture
get started at shipstation.com today
click on the microphone right at the
tippy top of the home page
and type in rogue that's shipstation.com
then enter the code rogue
shipstation.com
make ship happen a little naughty
a little bit naughty speaking of naughty
let's get to our second ad
and it's gonna be a little spicy a
little bit spicy
guys let's thank today's sponsor and
someone that has sponsored many a lonely
winter evening in upstate new york
adamandeve.com adam and eve says the
best part of staying at home
is playing at home and they're not
talking checkers they're not talking
chess
they're not talking twister they're
talking straight up
essen effin tien cuen aren
dippin twist in everything you can
imagine your filthy mind goes there adam
and eve's got something
to shepherd you they're like sexual
sherpas i love these people
all of this down time gives us time to
get down i know i'm getting down am i
getting down with anybody no that's
where adam and eve comes in built in
three
big bang boom all right take advantage
of this downtime and choose almost any
item from adamandeve.com
50 off when you do you're also going to
get 10
free boredom busting gifts that's more
than santa brings you
okay these people are erotic santa
clauses what is santa you ate presents
these people are throwing in 10 free
gifts the second you order something
and that's uh six spicy movies a
three-piece bonus kit which let your
mind wander there three whole pieces
and best of all free shipping delivered
discreetly right to your door
no i have no shame i say leave it out of
the packaging just drop that dildo right
on my front porch what do i care
but yeah mail it to the neighbor i want
him to know what i'm doing that's right
let my neighbor know she's a very nice
woman but she should
never watch take it out of the package
and just suction it right on the front
door
pink just like a like a bow and arrow
from hawkeye
pink right to the door all right where
were we all this shopping at home is
more convenient right now
more than ever you want to do this stuff
from home and shopping for adult stuff
is just this much more convenient with
adam and eve just remember to use the
offer code theory that's t-h-e-o-r-y
you ain't got no alibi unless you call
adam and eve or go to their website
don't call them i mean at this point who
wants to hear a phone call what is this
2003 text a different service text them
you
up okay and make sure you type in theory
at checkout okay adam and eve has
thousands of products to make you glad
you're staying at home i may never leave
the house again
and by the way i'm dehydrated can i
order does abbott eve have gatorades i
don't know either way i'm losing
fluids rapidly with adam and eve go to
adamandeve.com and use that offer code
theory i love you all very much we want
to thank our friends at manscape for
sponsoring this episode
manscape offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels and if
you're
ever going to treat yourself to
something that's precision engineered
it should be something you shear your
gorgeous ball sack with is that not
right boss look at that thing look at
our spokes
model eric boss isn't he gorgeous look
at him it's oh wow he's using
it right now i think they spent
18 ago there's about 18
guys really going for it not a drop of
blood daddy
wow that's great uh proud of you son
they spent 18 months that's two
pregnancies
three if you're using drugs during them
during
to build the lawnmower 3.0 the greatest
body hair trimmer the world
has ever seen it's waterproof that's
important
it has 90 minute battery that's equally
important however i will say
if you reach minute 70 with the
manscaper take a break
sit down let everything cool out there's
obviously a situation going there
if you're manscaping you're growing for
90 minutes so
if you hit like what would be the length
of a christopher guest mockumentary
somewhere between 73 and 82 minutes
go ahead and set that bad boy down uh
this thing has a 90 minute battery which
is incredible
it even has an led light so you can see
what you're doing
that's pretty nice you know it gets hard
it gets hard
and also it's difficult to shave your
jewels manscaping accidents are a thing
of the past think the manscapes
skin safe technology skin safe
technology if we can do it with manscape
why can't we just do it and end
vampire terrorism okay if we can keep
the skin safe
they can't bite us we need to use the
technology from the razors
for our necks anyway i'm going on a
tangent here they've also got
quiet stroke technology on their 7000
rpm trimmer motor
i use quiet stroke technology now that
i'm living with my mom again
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code rogue theory
at manscape.com 20 off and free shipping
at manscape.com and use the promo code
rogue theory okay rogue
theory let's get everybody cleaned up
for the holidays let's move on to the
scourge rogue theory
discord rogue theory speaking of
verdicts like the one i just gave every
week
we play a rogue theory with our patrons
on the new rockstars discord it's where
everything happens
it's the studio 54 of geek culture
there's cocaine
there's illicit hookups in the bathroom
there's uh
people optioning film scripts i'm sure i
don't know i'm usually asked to leave
because i don't play by the rules of the
forum
so i usually get about three comments in
before someone very politely says
that's not what we do in this forum this
is where we discuss uh beetlejuice
and i say beetlejuice porn and they're
like no just beetlejuice
this week we had some patrons pitch
theories
about the second season of amazon series
the boys
personal favorite of mine we had some
really really really good theories this
week including some
bangers from sandman and john james john
james
john james but our winner was mlgx what
does that stand for
with their theory that homelander will
be briefly joining up with the boys to
defeat stormfront before of course
turning evil again and killing all kinds
of folks that
that does make sense you can play too
and have your theory read on an episode
of rogue theory by a barely literate man
child
uh all you have to do is become a patron
of new rockstars and join our discord
also if you haven't already watch the
first season of the boys we're going to
be covering the second season on this
channel
please involve me and you'll want to be
all caught up okay
you're gonna catch up on it chit chat
with me about the boys i love talking
about the boys i love talking about the
girls i love talking about the boys and
girls together
now around to our second topic the
secret wars series and game directors
the russo brothers
did an interview this week where they
mentioned again how much they'd like to
direct a secret wars movie
let's get this going guys and how they
think it could be even bigger than end
game
if anyone's gonna know it's gonna be
them gentlemen pitch me
on how this famous comic story line
could come to the big screen at some
point in the mcu future boss why you go
first
okay so um what is secret wars for those
who don't know it was like a 1985
comic crossover event where like all the
marvel heroes and villains just get
like teleported to this strange place
that we later find out is battle world
and they were brought there by who we
later learned is the beyonder
and he's kind of just like pid them all
against each other and there's all kinds
of interesting alignments between heroes
and villains it was
the reason the russo brothers say this
could be like the best marvel movie of
all time is it's just like
endgame on crack because it's like an
even bigger crossover event that just
doesn't
even try to justify it with like time or
physics
it's just like what if this guy could
just like take everyone
into his toy box and mix them all up so
practically the way i think this would
have to work is it's going to
take years in order to like reset
everything to have
everyone appear in the movie at the same
time again it's like a decade away
but there's a way you can lead up to it
in a cool
like uh slow drip kind of way so
now that like you know things are now
moving towards streaming series and i
think disney plus is gonna find out
between one of vision falcon winter
soldier loki that's gonna be the way to
go episodic storytelling the way comic
books are meant to be told
and you can still fund it with just as
big of a budget what if we have a battle
world
and a secret wars style event to where
it's just episodic
you know just maybe every week or every
month you have a special event
where it is two two characters from the
mcu you can afford
a budget of just bringing back let's say
uh
ultron versus red skull you can bring
those two actors back they just do a
quick uh
battle and they're done and then you
have like basically uh
a tournament you know that you work your
way up to who are gonna be the champions
and then it's just like a versus series
this character versus this character
uh you can have um uh pietro maximov
versus hawkeye and then finally there
he's trying to like fire those zeros out
of he finally
wants to pull back the arrow he's like
i'm gonna get you this time you're gonna
see it coming
you know and we can work our way up
toward a big crossover event but that
way
you can spread out the secret wars
conflict
over the course of years and just have
uh someone get transported from at a
time
and then it's just two characters we
haven't seen in a while and aren't going
to see in a
fight in the future he didn't have like
uh we don't know what's gonna happen
with hulk and roadie
you know like they aren't attached to
any big title coming up
you can have them fight and duke it out
in a battle world event and and that way
we can we can build up to
the big movie of secret wars and they
can do it as like a three-parter
i'm sold i'm done i like that excellent
all right uh very good erica wuzu what
is your pitch for a secret voicemail
i like i like the secret wars kind of
rumors sniffing this aroma
out in the air from the russo brothers a
lot uh it smells good it smells like
money
but i like with the secret wars movie
being a huge movie event
the way uh end game was where everyone
or as many people as possible
who are available who could be made
available uh paid
handsome amounts of money or given their
children back because they were taken
ransom by marvel so they can get this
thing done
that happens yeah so we get everyone
together
uh tom holland robert downey jr chris
evans everyone who said they're done
bring them back in like that mobster
movie i can't remember the name of uh
the godfather part two i believe
every time they pull me out every time i
try to get out they pull me back in
that's why you're the king thomas all
right now
uh and i i really like i'd like a secret
wars movie to work
kind of like the so there was a two-part
episode of the spider-man animated
series in the 90s
where they did a secret wars kind of
small arc where what voss said happened
a bunch of heroes were teleported to
this world to kind of
prove that good was better than evil and
they brought in a bunch of villains they
brought in the lizard
so i think that could happen in the
movie but also in the movie i want it to
kind of function like a kingdom hearts
type of event scenario
yeah where we we follow a specific hero
or
character as they go to different parts
of the planet
and see different heroes battling it out
with different villains so that way we
could actually have what voss was saying
and like having two actors at a time
three actors four actors at a time
uh doing different parts of the movie
but we just kind of space it out over a
movie or two movies maybe even three
movies
yes a trilogy yes a nice little marvel
trilogy yeah
the secret wars yes i like that
i like that very much uh you you you
brought up kingdom hearts
shout out to my boy riku shout out to my
girl kyrie
shout out to my boy sora and then
negative sora which i believe is called
roxas i don't know it's been a long time
something like that but i do i do love
those games and i love your idea for the
movie guys
i feel like i've let us all astray this
is uh we're at a time right now where
everybody's so divided
i've made you guys fight i i was the
beyonder of this situation i pulled you
from your world
what and i made you fight for my
pleasure but i'm going to retire
for one second judge thomas michael
bechtold and i'm going to introduce you
guys to another guy
this is big time hollywood producer t
michael beck told
and i want you to work together now to
pitch me
in concert your two ideas i want you to
work together to punch up your secret
wars pitches
to give me one solid unified team worked
out pitch okay
on secret wars i need you to combine
your powers and we'll begin right after
this
hey guys thanks for coming to my office
at 7
30 on a friday afternoon in santa monica
that's a long drive
i love what you guys did with your
treatment i love the treatment treatment
was amazing but i need you to wow me
right now
with uh with an in-the-room pitch go
ahead go ahead
okay um we're not going to waste time
because we know you don't validate
parking
but uh myself eric boss my friend erica
wusu
we got a pitch that's gonna blow your
pants off uh and it's a
hybrid uh battle world secret wars
marvel crossover event that will explore
the different
realms of uh of battle world
that from different points of view but
doing it uh
one movie at a time every year of the
decade
of 2020 through 2030 one 90-minute event
that explores uh a different corner of
the marvel world
so uh my manawusu's going to pitch you
the first uh the first episode of it
uh just to give you a sense of it
amazing yeah and the first episode
uh before all your cocaine runs out is
gonna be spider-man and all the young
avengers
and even the new mutants thrown in there
all the young new hot
avenger superheroes uh versus
new villains that we haven't seen in the
mcu yet so dr
doom right um uh uh that's all i can
think of right now
he's a galactic galactic conqueror
yeah uh and whoever the silver surfer
doesn't like all those people
are going to go to war and we're going
to bring the the new kids and
fans of the old comics together to watch
these heroes and villains duke it out
on the big screen and imax 4k bang yeah
also going to take it over
so that's the pilot one uh well we'll
get you the the show bible for the other
nine episodes but we'll tell you the
final one we're going to save you a lot
of money
we're just going to be using uh uh
stuntmen and suits which you know a lot
of the stunts are done by stuntmen
anyway
and then when iron man's visor opens
it's just going to be robert downey jr's
face rotoscoped
from one of the other past movies so
that way we don't need to pay any of
these actors to come back
just like appearance fees for whatever
they're you know using their likeness
but that's it we're going to have them
all fight just like toys and we're going
to have other uh voice over actors the
way that they had that guy from walking
dead do the voice for red skull
and infinity war that's we're going to
do for all of these characters
you're welcome yeah boys let me tell you
a little story when i was
producing baby commandos my diapers full
of my gun clips empty
i was told i would never work in this
town again
and i took a risk and i made baby
commandos too
by rattles louder than my shotgun
nobody told me to make that movie we
lost a hundred million dollars but what
you just told me
is a hundred billion dollar idea i'm
green lighting the idea i would do just
a little more cocaine
and uh we're gonna start working on that
wait uh are you are you okay sir oh my
god
can you can you just sign something
before you before you oh [ __ ] oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god no no no
we can't we can we can at bernie's him
we'll keep him alive we'll get this
movie made one way or another
i like it just electro it's just right
in the front of the nipples they'll keep
them alive yeah
and now i'm back as the honorable judge
thomas beck told
uh to give you my decision and that is
that you work together wonderfully
so i'm calling that round a tie uh
i do really enjoy that theory i like
eric i love
boss i love the idea of um
of of starting it out on on the disney
plus platform building to the movies
almost as
like these little like uh featurettes i
i love that i love those
those theories i i liked it when you
worked together because i like seeing my
eric's work together guys
i love i love i love what speaking of
the boys season two
my boys season one is happening right
now and they're coming together for
secret wars theories but
now i must rip us all apart as we
compete for uh
rogue questions which i will participate
in since there's only two of
uh two of you and uh let's see here
real question number one in a recent
interview mandalorian and wonder woman
1984 actor pedro pascal
said that he preferred working with gal
gadot organized uh
over baby yoda wow gal over baby yo
what kind of diva behavior could baby
yoda have possibly done
on set to make his castmates throw shade
at him like this
i'm gonna say baby yoda that that
floating egg that he would hover around
in
he filled it with little yoda turds just
like a hamster in a cage that the kid
forgot to take home over the weekend
and it was a long spring break and and
then covet happened
so that hamster is still there just uh
shooting his way to the top so he can
climb his way to freedom
and that's what baby ever did all right
that makes sense uh
i think he preferred working with yogado
over baby yoda because i think baby yoda
is too damn cute
so i think baby yoda suffers from mariah
carey syndrome
where he's too damn cute but is vicious
and nasty
under the surface and just makes life a
living hell
even though he's adorable so i think
that's why
i don't think this is a baby yo problem
i think this is a gado
solution i would rather work with gal
gadot than my dead grandmother coming
back to life like i would
i mean like in any situation where i
could work with gal gadot i'm going to
do that
i don't i mean i i i don't understand
that to me that's no contest i'm sorry
baby yoda's not even that hot uh okay
question two
in honor of the 20th anniversary of the
first x-men movie my god i'm old
producer ralph winter did an interview
where he mentioned some people who were
seeking to be cast in the first film
including mariah carey as storm
shaquille o'neal as forge and
michael jackson as professor x
in this wild alternative x universe
who else would you cast to round out
this team okay i'm trying to imagine
this being like a 90s
uh or a late 80s pitch maybe but i'm
gonna say
uh shania twain is rogue so that she
could sing uh
like man i feel like a mutant
and then uh and then let's say mr t
is magneto just so he can attract more
metallic things to his necklace
i think it would be hilarious to have
have had david hasselhoff play cyclops
so that he could have the visor on and
he could drive around the
x-men academy in kit knight rider and
then
it's red visor thing in the front of it
would be going back and forth
yes that's just a fun visual for me yes
uh and and then i
like kobe bryant yes playing wolverine
yes yes yes
they have like little afro puffs instead
of yeah
oh my god i just love that wow i love
that in general
uh uh little known fact maybe not so
little though david hasselhoff actually
played nick fury
uh that's right that was the first song
in a tv movie right nick fury agent of
shield
director of shield or something like
that uh so
hasselhoff was in the mcu before the mcu
even knew what it was uh for me
for me i think you gotta go uh jim
carrey is nightcrawler
uh chris farley is beast and
uh rounding things out i would go with
um let me see here
elf as jubilee elf the alien puppet
that's jubilee makes sense
yeah that's my uh that's who i miss the
trench coat is that it
yeah yeah and alf loved them all too
that's right all right finally
uh and something i've been looking very
forward to guys this week
taco bell shattered hearts and probably
preserved lives
by announcing that they're eliminating
some items from their menus
so i present to you this mini lightning
round
with rogue questions where you have to
guess whether something i tell you is a
real menu from taco bell
no real menu item from taco bell that
they're eliminating or something
off-screen producer zach just made up
so uh just just ring in see
and uh or and let me know uh beefy
fritos burrito
um real thing that is real yeah
maybe we both just answer and then you
give a point to whoever's right
perfect perfect i like it all right so
you guys are wrong so you guys both get
a point for that one all right
1-1 second mini skillet breakfast bowls
that's real i'm gonna say that's not a
real thing okay that is a real thing
so yeah erica has two
uh eric boss has one [ __ ]
next thing a funyuns hard taco that's
not real obviously that's not real
either
that's fake that is fake okay uh
stuffed shredders that's real uh real
thing
that is fake
all right loaded griller fake fake
what's a griller i don't know it's
something you used to be able to get at
taco bell but it's gone now because that
is
real and finally finally we have a
plugged stuffer a plug stuffer
well that's gotta be real because taco
bell every time i use it i gotta use the
plunger to unstuck my toilet
there's no way a blown stuffer
is awesome no it's fake it's fake
uh i was about to bet the farm on it
it's fake it's fake but
that answer alone i'm gonna have to give
erica
the uh the points for the uh for that
round so
let's see declaring a winner today is
really tough because it was virtually a
tie i gave you guys a tie i gave eric
round one and i gave eric
uh eric voss round one i gave you ty for
round two and eric woo
i gave you the points for a round for
the for the rogue question round
so uh i'm going gonna just have to ask
you a trivia question
this is it this is the championship this
is for today's game
this is the question that matters the
most i want you to guess what color
shorts i'm wearing
and be specific um can they be multiple
colors from stains that might be on them
absolutely absolutely and accurately yes
[Laughter]
um i'm going to say khaki
with uh uh orange
just uh uh one or two orange-ish red
stains
okay uh thank you thank you for assuming
i wear khakis great
i'm gonna say you're wearing green
mesh shorts with sour cream stains
from your taco bell earlier today
oh god i wish uh i'm gonna have to go
just based on fabric alone erica wussu
is the winner i am wearing
blue exercise shorts
with yellow coleman's mustard stains
from my nightly ritual of honey wheat
pretzels
dipped into hot mustard and by nightly i
do mean
these are the shorts i was wearing last
night eric you are our winner
what is your wish well uh you were right
and eric won
yes oh that's sorry erica wusu you are
our winner
you are you are the champion eric today
what is your wish you're the best eric
in my eyes
and to be fair you wear that anyway
you're a gentleman and the scholar tommy
sure my wish
is that eric voss even though it is no
longer ice cream national ice cream day
has a pint of his favorite ice cream oh
my god later today
on camera oh no just see that oh no just
at some point
you're on your
i can hold to that uh my favorite ice
cream is mcconnell's uh sprinkle cake
which is so great if you're if you live
in the la area mcconnell's you know it's
great
and you can't get cones right now well
they won't scoop it in cones and hand it
to you which is the best way to eat ice
cream
you got to get a pint you got to get a
pie all right
we'll get we'll get photo evidence of
that and put it on social media or
something that's it for this episode of
rogue theory thank you for going rogue
let's thank our guests
eric voss the king of all new rock stars
nerd knowledge
and our champion our champion
the wonderful erica wuzu eric thank you
so much for joining us
do not forget to subscribe to rogue
theory and the podcast feed and stay
tuned to the youtube channel for this
and other great shows and follow us on
twitter at new rockstars follow me
at tommybechtold follow these gentlemen
at their social medias we are proudly
displaying below
i love you all very much go bills josh
allen number one arm strength and madden
madden 21
well deserved suck it pat mahomes good
night
[Music]
you